it was billed as the Red Wave of 2022
Republicans winning control of Congress
to become President Joe Biden's biggest
political obstacle but Democrats have
won several important races Mark Kelly
of Arizona was re-elected to the Senate
he'll be joined by Pennsylvania's John
fetterman who overcame both a stroke and
stiff competition from the celebrity
doctor Mehmet Oz I'm proud of what we
ran on
Healthcare is a fundamental human right
it saved my life and it should all be
there for you
the midterms came after months of
Republicans accusing Democrats of
plotting to steal the vote despite fears
of potential disruptions at polling
stations nothing significant was
reported
the president spent Tuesday evening
congratulating Democrats who won their
races and he urged people still waiting
to vote in western states to stay in
line Democrats hopes died early though
in Florida where Republicans now control
all of the top seats we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob Florida is
where woke goes to die
well our country flounders due to failed
leadership in Washington Florida is on
the right track
former president Donald Trump promised
he would take credit for any Republican
victories and he did just that I wonder
what Biden would do right now but one of
the candidates Trump endorsed did not
thank him during his victory speech now
the people of Ohio have given us a job
and what we need to do over the next
couple of years over the next six years
for the full the full length of this
Senate term whoever's in the majority
whatever the president looks like we
have a very simple job to do it's to go
to work every single day and fight for
the people of Ohio let's get America
back on track House minority leader
Kevin McCarthy has long dreamed of
taking the speaker's gavel from Nancy
Pelosi but voters may not be ready for
that
Russell and Jordan Al Jazeera